so eine leserfrage wir jetzt von stefan
eckhardt dies ganz typisch für diese
zeit weil natürlich viele leute auch im
voraus gebucht haben wir sind ja ein
volk von frühbuchern wir brauchen ja
eigentlich schon im herbst für den
nächsten sommer das wundert auch zum
teil die ausländer in großbritannien ist
es zum beispiel so da wird sehr
kurzfristig gebucht aber wir buchen
rechtzeitig und ob das ein fehler ist
werden wir gleich wissen
stephanie beckert hat uns eine
videobotschaft geschickt ich habe fragen
zu einer reise nach mallorca
zwar haben wir mit einer einer
befreundeten familie für anfang juni
eine finca auf mallorca gebucht und für
diese reise wird jetzt in zwei wochen
die nächste rate fällig bzw die nächste
storno frist verstreicht und wir
bekommen leider von dem büro wo wir die
finca gebucht haben also es ist ein
vermittlungsbüro keine informationen
dazu was passiert wenn wir im juni nicht
reisen können dh sie können uns nicht
sagen ob wir dann unser geld zurück
bekommen ob wir umbuchen können so dass
wir jetzt halt uns fragen ob es für uns
sicherer ist zu stornieren und 30
prozent der reisekosten dann ja umsonst
bezahlt haben oder ob wir lieber
abwarten sollten
wie ist da ihre meinung zu stefanie
egger spricht ein wirklich wichtiges
problem an
tatsächlich hat man zum teil ja auch die
möglichkeit bei langfristig gebuchten
reisen jetzt noch zu stornieren und zum
teil eine stornogebühr vielleicht von 30
prozent oder 40 prozent zu bezahlen
dass es immer noch billiger als wenn ich
dann am ende 100 prozent zahlen muss und
deswegen auch gleich die frage weiter an
arndt kempgens jetzt ruhig bleiben
panikartig stornieren um geld zu sparen
was sagt der chef und der experte also
das ist was wir in vielen fällen im
moment das ist ja so die klassische
reise frage und wir hören immer wieder
diese hinhaltetaktik die veranstalter
die gesellschaften antworten nicht so
richtig sehr verzögert weil sie auch
irgendwie uns reißt
hinhalten und der reise sollte meines
erachtens jetzt genauso antworten eben
auch inhalten und zwar seine zahlungen
inhalten denn dadurch gewinnt er ja zeit
denn wenn das geld jetzt erst mal
bezahlt ist vertragsgemäß denn es gibt
ja diese zahlungsfristen dann ist das
geld erst mal weg und ob ich es in
welcher form wieder bekommen als
gutschein als bargeld ob es überhaupt
nur die rückzahlungsmöglichkeit geht
wenn also auch diese weiteren reisen
abgesagt werden müssen steht völlig in
den sternen weiß im moment noch niemand
und wenn ich jetzt schon storniere dann
muss ich natürlich die
stornierungskosten zahlen
das im grunde genommen das solle
prognostische entscheidung ist gehe ich
davon aus dass die reise stattfindet
dann ist es ja gut gehe ich davon aus
dass die reise corona bedenkt abgesagt
wird dann sollte man jetzt nicht
stornieren weil man dann die
stornierungskosten bezahlen muss und
wenn es jetzt darum geht dass man
weitere anzahlungen leisten soll da
sollte man eher hinhaltetaktik üben also
tatsächlich auch noch mal ein wichtiger
hinweis von mir angst wer angst hat
mensch in diesem sommer möchte ich gar
nicht verreisen da habe ich angst um
meine gesundheit darf ich angst sich
anzustecken ist leider kein relevanter
grund vom reisevertrag zurückzutreten
also tatsächlich müssen sie wenn sie
dieser meinung sind tatsächlich auch
stornokosten bezahlen dann wird es halt
schwer